uh Ari let me bring you into this um
I've been saying a lot on the air that
Donald Trump defies all conventional
political gravity uh usually you would
think that if somebody gets arrested if
somebody gets indicted that their poll
numbers would go down in every case his
have gone up and I I wonder if it's been
such Overkill because this started the
day that he and Melania Trump came down
that escalator leading into you know
three long years of what turned out to
be nothing but lies and conspiracy
theories pedal by fake news CNN MSNBC
The New York Times uh three broadcast
network The Washington Post they all
seem to be wrong they all were wrong
rather and I wonder if in some odd way
they took a man like Donald Trump and
they actually have turned him into a
victim and people see through this and N
none of what they now do matters to
people because of all the fundamental
unfairness that led up to this
point you know Sean the the we have gaps
in this country people say a gender gap
there's this Gap there's that Gap the
biggest Gap we have is actually between
the mainstream media and the American
people specifically college educated
Democrats who are really reporters the
mainstream media ABC NBC CBS The New
York Times The Washington Post and their
failure to understand the country they
live in outside it's elite bubbles it's
cities it's college educated campuses
they do not understand the rural voters
of Iowa they will parachute in interview
them
talk about what these people believe in
and then leave and not understand their
way of life their way of thinking their
way of being raised in a gun culture
their way of fishing it is such a
desperate group of people but the
majority of course are those type of
Americans who are not the college
educated Democrats reporters and that's
why they missed the story of
2016 and that's why I think that you you
have still so many people cheering for
the defeat of Donald Trump who are out
of touch with such a huge swath of this
country Donald Trump to his credit is
intuitively in touch with them and
you're seeing that tonight on the ground
in Iowa these results are really
staggering if they hold up for president
Trump president is important history is
important and Donald Trump is shattering
it this year with the margin of his
victory even if he falls short of 50 his
margin between first and second is
massive now for that second because I do
think it's still as important and we all
need to recognize New Hampshire has a
very different electoral makeup than
Iowa does far more college educated far
more moderate that would play to Nikki
Haley's benefit you have to presume and
if she wins in second in Iowa it will
boost her going to New Hampshire Haley's
problem though based on the results
tonight is she's got to crack
conservatives she cannot win on the
basis of liberal moderate Republicans
alone with some help from Independence
she's got to do better among true blue
conservatives and that's where in Iowa
at least there's no evidence that
anybody can run against Donald Trump
well that's interesting I I've always
felt that the fact New Hampshire allows
Independents to decide whether they
prefer to vote in a Democratic primary
or the Republican primary uh AR great
analysis thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else